[Música]
nuevo espacio de economía aquí en
directo a América Daniela hablando
bienvenida a este estudio Gracias
Daniela Vamos hasta Estados Unidos
porque el gobierno de Joe biden parece
que quiere apretar a las aerolíneas para
que de alguna manera hagan un poco de
esfuerzo con sus clientes Claro en la
casa blanca lo que quiere es imponer a
finales de este año un requisito legal a
las aerolíneas para que compensen a los
pasajeros por vuelo retrasados o
cancelados cuando Estas son las
responsables por ejemplo cuando tienen
problemas mecánicos con el avión o
cuando les falta la tripulación en
concreto buscan que cubran gastos como
comidas y hoteles si dejan varados a los
pasajeros además de devolver el valor
del tiquete algo que ellas hacen de
manera voluntaria en este momento pero
sería obligatorio y algo que también ya
es normal en Canadá o en la Unión
Europea
en la última temporada de vacaciones Los
viajeros quedaron varados durante días
Muchos se perdieron reuniones familiares
pasaron a Navidad en un aeropuerto
esperaron incontables horas en la fila o
al teléfono porque no había suficientes
pilotos y no había suficiente personal
eso es inaceptable Y aunque los retrasos
y cancelaciones de vuelo se han reducido
desde entonces todavía Hay un problema
Los viajeros aéreos estadounidenses
merecen algo mejor bueno Y ante estas
posibles exigencias que han dicho las
aerolíneas Pues a ver el gobierno dice
que en principio se han resistido a
ofrecer compensaciones en efectivo y ya
las aerolíneas como tal Airlines for
América que es el gremio que las
aglutina asegura que los retrasos o
cancelaciones por lo general no son
responsabilidad suya y que la
administración Federal de Aviación es la
que no tiene suficiente personal y por
eso es que se causan estos retrasos pues
veremos a ver cómo sigue este tema
Daniela seguimos en Estados Unidos
porque los guionistas de Hollywood van
Ya a la segunda semana de huelga y hay
nuevos programas que se han visto
afectados claro cuando empezamos a
hablar de este tema hace una semana se
dijo que la huelga del del
América solamente afectaría los
programas en vivo pero con el pasar de
los días la lista se está agrandando ya
Warner Bros detuvo la escritura de una
próxima precuela de Game of thrones la
última temporada también del éxito de
Netflix stranger things también fue
pausada así como la producción de Blade
de Marvel que ya iba a comenzar
filmación los actores también se han
solidarizado el domingo fue la gala de
los famosos MTV movie MTV Awards
inicialmente programado para ir en vivo
Este programa se redujo a una
pregrabación y se canceló la famosísima
alfombra roja muchas celebridades Y
presentadores no asistieron y en su
lugar mostraron palabras de solidaridad
casi toda la gran comedia comienza con
grandes escritores
estoy aquí ante ustedes esta noche al
lado de mis hermanas y hermanos del
sindicato de guionistas que están
luchando ahora mismo luchando por los
derechos de los escritores en todas
partes
vamos más al sur Daniela del continente
americano porque la inflación anual en
China en Chile bajo un dígito pues se
ubicó en 9,9% en los 12 meses que
terminaron en abril la primera
diferencia de un solo dígito a nivel
interanual en un año con el servicio de
transporte aéreo también la electricidad
las consultas médicas los arriendos los
paquetes turísticos y la carne de vacuno
todo esto marcando alzas en estos
índices ahora si lo comparamos con las
cifras anualizadas de otros países de la
región que ya han reportado datos hasta
abril chile está en un nivel promedio lo
vamos a ver en el gráfico está por
encima de Paraguay de Honduras también
es Uruguay también tiene una inflación
mucho menor que en Colombia hoy también
se conoció precisamente el informe
mensual del observatorio venezolano de
finanzas que es una entidad
independiente al margen del Banco
Central y esta vez dice que la inflación
interanual en abril fue del 471 por
ciento es muy alta pero es menor a la de
marzo que fue del 501% según esta
entidad bueno menor pero a ver quién
nota la diferencia con esas cifras de
inflación Daniela vamos ya con Los
indicadores de las bolsas
en un inicio de semana en el que los
bancos están recuperando en bolsa y con
los ojos puestos en el dato de inflación
de abril que se conocerá el próximo
miércoles las acciones europeas
terminaron al alza de encabezadas por
las bancarias y las de atención médica
solamente Alemania cerró a la baja entre
las principales en América Latina vamos
a destacar hoy chile con un repunte del
más del 2%, después del resultado de las
elecciones constituyentes que
consagraron como ya lo decíamos en los
noticieros a la ultraderecha como fuerza
más importante de este órgano que va a
redactar la segunda propuesta de
Constitución Daniela pues muchas gracias
como siempre por este repaso económico
vamos ya con directo a